JUDITH D. SINGER: Thank you all.
I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the senior vice provost
for faculty development
and diversity, and I
am also a professor
of statistics at the
Graduate School of Education.
And on behalf of
all of Harvard, I
would like to invite you to
this new faculty institute.
This is the 11th year that
we've been doing this,
and it's a chance to
bring together faculty
from across the university
to meet each other;
to hear from colleagues who
have, like you, once been new;
and to hear, in today's
case, from someone who's just
as new as you, the 29th
president of Harvard
University, Lawrence S. Bacow.
I'm just going to
say a few words,
and then I'm going to turn the
podium over to President Bacow.
And then I'll come pop up
and say a few more words.
What I hope is that both today
and also in the experiences
that you've had over
the last few weeks,
you've gotten a chance to see
what a terrific place Harvard
is to be a faculty member.
We know that all of you
had lots of options.
Anybody we want to
hire wants to be
hired by a lot of other
institutions as well,
and we are so thrilled
that you made the decision
to join us here.
You're going to have fabulous
colleagues, fabulous students.
You're going to discover that
the Harvard name, for better
or worse, opens doors.
And it's also just a terrific
place to do research.
But since President
Bacow is with us,
I'm going to yield the podium
because he takes rank over me.
And I think he needs
no introduction.
I think the one
piece of introduction
I would give you is that Harvard
is not quite 400 years old,
and he is the 29th president.
So just wrap your
head around that.
You're going to
live a long time.
[LAUGHTER]
LAWRENCE S. BACOW: From
your lips to God's ears.
JUDITH D. SINGER: Exactly.
LAWRENCE S. BACOW: And
let's hope she's listening.
JUDITH D. SINGER: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
LAWRENCE S. BACOW:
Well, as Judy said,
I am also a new faculty member.
My faculty appointment
was processed
at exactly the same
time all of yours were.
So I would like to say
I'm delighted to be
a member of your class,
and I look forward
to getting to know many of you
in a variety of different kinds
of capacities.
As I was saying to
Judy and your panelists
up here when we were
just talking in advance,
this sort of brought
me back in time
to when I was welcomed as
a very, very junior faculty
member--
it's hard to admit this--
41 years ago at MIT.
I spent the bulk of
my career at MIT.
And Judy asked
me, so what advice
did they give you back then.
And I actually do remember.
I said, god, I can't remember.
Then I remembered the advice
I was given back then.
So I will share that
advice with you right now.
And this is more applicable to
those of you who are joining us
as your first faculty
appointment as opposed
to those of you who are lateral
moves and have been faculty
members elsewhere and are
coming here, in some cases,
as full professors.
I was advised to remember
that in a great university,
best idea wins.
It does not make any
difference what your rank is,
where you came from before.
Treat your faculty colleagues
and others exactly like that.
If you disagree with
them, disagree with them.
Stand up for your own
ideas, your own scholarship,
and you will do well.
It actually was
great, great advice.
I think it's actually
great advice not just
for faculty members.
I think it's great advice for
students and for others also.
Just a few weeks ago, I welcomed
entering first-year students.
And before that, I spoke to
first-year faculty advisors.
And when I spoke to
them, I made a point
of saying if you're going to
be a good faculty advisor,
it's really important
to try and remember
what it was like when
you were a student,
and you got sort of
the envelope saying
you've now been accepted to
blank, or the first time you
were appointed here at Harvard.
Students at Harvard talk
about dropping the H bomb,
that the fact that
we all work here,
study here-- whatever-- can
be intimidating for others.
But hopefully, it will certainly
not be for our students,
nor will it be for you.
The miracle of Harvard
is that we combine--
we take great students and
combine them with great faculty
under temperature and pressure,
and really interesting
catalytic reactions occur.
And the peer effects here are
really quite extraordinary,
and they make, I think,
everybody better.
That said, everybody
at one time or another
can find themselves
intimidated by the place.
It's true of new students.
It's true of new faculty.
It's true of new staff.
It's true of new presidents.
[LAUGHTER]
So my advice to you is to relax
and try and exploit the place
in every possible way.
Everybody who works here,
and I do mean everybody,
is invested in your success.
And people are
going to do whatever
they can to try and ensure
that you can do work here.
You can do scholarship
here that you
can do perhaps no other place.
And that is, I think--
our collective goal
is to surround you with great
students; great colleagues;
great staff; hopefully, great
facilities and resources.
The resources, I
know, will never
be enough because faculty
have an insatiable
appetite for resources.
That's how it should be.
But we are here
to try and ensure
that you can do truly,
truly great things.
So let me just stop there.
By the way, I am
not President Bacow.
I'm Larry.
That's what everybody calls me.
So when you see
me around, please
stop and say, hello, Larry.
And don't hesitate to
stop me and tell me
how things are going for you.
JUDITH D. SINGER:
Thanks, Larry, very much.
I'm just going to
say a few words
about the university, the sort
of payback on Phil's question.
There are some
things that you're
going to learn about
Harvard in your years
here that you see it from
the perspective of being
in your individual school or
your individual department,
but there's a big
superstructure.
And I'm not talking about it
in lumbering administration.
I'm talking about just
a big superstructure
for the entire university.
Harvard is a huge place.
Among our Ivy League,
Ivy Plus peers,
we're larger than
pretty much everyone.
And so it means that
you have to work harder
to break through those
kinds of boundaries.
There are about 1,500 ladder
faculty across the university.
And then we have our
Harvard-affiliated hospitals.
There are 18
Harvard-affiliated hospitals,
and they have another
11,000 faculty.
So if you start to wrap your
head around the sheer magnitude
of it, there's just a lot of
opportunity to meet people.
And there are a
lot of people who
are doing interesting
work that we'd like
you to be able to partake of.
I'd also say that Harvard
is increasingly diverse.
And if you take a
look at this room,
this is not your
father's Harvard.
When I started on
the faculty in 1984,
I can tell you I was one of
the few women on the faculty
at the university.
That is just not
the case anymore.
Overall at the
university, we're now--
30% of the ladder faculty are
female, 24% are minorities.
And the entering class--
you in this room--
are particularly diverse--
37% female, 38% minority.
Another feature of
Harvard right now,
and this is more directed
towards the newly tenured
faculty who are here--
you're all coming
from the outside,
but Harvard has moved
to a tenure track.
And so increasingly, your
tenured colleagues, especially
your earlier career
tenured colleagues,
will have come up from within.
And this is a huge
sea change in terms
of the sense of the university
and sense of investing
in people.
We are really invested
in every single faculty
member that comes here who
are invested in their success.
This whole question of one
Harvard and the tub system--
you're in a changing era.
So Drew used the
phrase "one Harvard."
I think Larry is
continuing to adopt it.
And the idea is
that you should be
building on the connections that
exist across the university.
And in fact, the
panelists we have here are
a really good illustration of
those kinds of connections.
The decentralization was cited
as one of Harvard's successes
in an era before technology
and before we were all
connected to each other.
This is a very
different kind of era.
And we are actually working
on technological tools
to help you meet other
faculty with common interests
across the university.
Stay tuned to that.
We're working on developing
some faculty dashboards that
can help you meet other people
from across the university.
In the meantime, I am
the human faculty finder.
So if you are intere--
they're all nodding
because they know
I'm the human faculty finder.
We are very interested
in faculty development
and diversity in facilitating
these connections.
So just drop us a line, and
we are happy to hook you up.
I send emails to
people all the time,
electronically introducing
them to each other.
And the whole
rationale for today
is to bring people together
from across the university
and at different career stages.
And we're going to hear
from our colleagues
from also across Harvard
at different career
stages about their experiences
and advice to new faculty.